in less than two hours liquor will be
declared illegal by decree of the
distinguished gentlemen of our nation's
Congress to those beautiful ignorant
bastards alcohol prohibition may have
been repealed in 1933 but Americans have
rarely been more intoxicated with the
noble experiment than they are today
between last call Daniel Okrent
best-selling 2010 book leading clothing
designers taking inspiration from Jazz
Age fashions a new primetime documentary
by Ken Burns and the second season of
HBO's critically acclaimed Boardwalk
Empire it's impossible to ignore the new
interest in prohibition even drinking
culture seems to be belying up to the
ball
this is PDT or please don't tell which
can only be accessed by picking up that
telephone what's fueling this
fascination reason TV talked to
legendary filmmaker Ken Burns whose
Prohibition documentary is now hitting
the PBS airwaves III think there's
always a superficial interest in
prohibition you know you've got
gangsters everybody wants to be able to
kill the people who pissed them off
you've got women who are seemingly
promiscuous the you know the flapper
dancing with the short skirt and the
bobbed hair on top of the tables but I
think in every case Dan's book Boardwalk
Empire in our film it's the
understanding that prohibition reveals a
lot more author Daniel Okrent is one of
the central voices in the PBS
documentary it so doesn't fit our
conception of how we operate as a people
of our sense of the freedom of the
individual that when you are confronted
with it it's kind of inescapably
interesting and many observers are
finding analogies between prohibition
and today culture and art right now are
reflective of a general sentiment in
this society that the war on drugs has
not worked
Aaron Hewson is executive director of
the Washington dc-based students for
sensible drug policy if you look at the
art you analyze how the art was
portrayed just 20 years ago 30 years ago
The Untouchables right The Untouchables
was black and white
there's no in-between there was no
discussion of whether alcohol
prohibition sucked or didn't a show like
Boardwalk Empire actually highlights
this is not a black and white issue
there's a huge gray area in between we
got a product the fellas gotta have the
parallel between the war on booze as
represented by prohibition and the war
against marijuana and recreational drugs
today is that they're failures they
inevitably will fail they create
criminal syndicates they deprive the
government of tax revenue they do all
sorts of things that serve no one's
interest in are very much not in our
general social interest and marijuana
and alcohol prohibition may not just
function similarly there's good reason
to think they may end the same way
prohibition ended more than any other
reason because the depression came and
the federal government was suddenly not
collecting nearly as much as it had an
income tax and didn't collect anything
at all in capital gains taxes for four
years we live now in a culture where
taxes very unpopular where the idea of
user tax is quite popular and I think
that we will see the legalization of
marijuana in certain states come about
because of the need to fulfill to fill
the state Treasuries one of the most
interesting stories I have from being a
lobbyist on Capitol Hill marijuana
lobbyists on Capitol Hill we sit around
a table with about ten lobbyists and a
member of Congress and in general most
of them would go around the table and
talk about their tax issues and how
they've got a burdensome tax issue in
the airline industry and in another
industry they'd prefer not to see new
taxes and they would get to me and me
being the marijuana lobbyists and I
would say congressman I've got good news
here for you I'm not here to ask you for
a tax break we're the only people who
are gonna come here and ask to be taxed
things certainly seem to be heading that
way last year almost 47% of Californians
voted for a ballot initiative that would
have legalized recreational marijuana
and similar tax and regulate
propositions will be on the 2012 ballot
in states such as Colorado in Washington
earlier this year Republican congressman
Ron Paul and Democratic congressman
Barney Frank introduced the first ever
bill to repeal federal laws against
marijuana and polls show historically
high and still rising levels of support
for legalizing and regulating
Oana similar to the way we do with
liquor actually one of the benefits of
Prohibition despite this horrible
inheritance of organized crime and all
the other bad things it did is that it
gives us pause when somebody comes and
said you know what we need is we need
this amendment or we need that amendment
we just kind of go wait a second because
the memory of prohibition and those
unintended consequences are fresh until
we do finally learn the lessons of
prohibition will likely keep debating
the equally disastrous outcomes of our
failed drug war through art culture and
the media for Reason TV I'm Nikolas